ce qui est préoccupant c'est qu'il ya
plusieurs bactéries qui sont en train de
devenir résistantes à tous les
antibiotiques dont on dispose qui sont
en train de devenir incurable on parle
autant de bactéries et du milieu
hospitalier que des bactéries banque
trouve dans le sol dans les aliments
comme la salmonelle les bactéries qui
causent la qu'honorer la tuberculose
alors tôt ou tard certaines de ces
infections vont devenir incurable par le
passé il y avait toujours des
antibiotiques pour venir nous secourir
mais là vraiment la chaîne de production
d'antibiotiques est vide ou presque il
n'y a pas de nouveaux antibiotiques qui
arrive parce que notamment il ya eu un
désinvestissement dans les dernières
années parce que il ya des obstacles
importants en sciences pour trouver des
nouveaux antibiotiques c'est difficile
faut se rappeler que la médecine moderne
telle qu'on la connaît repose sur cette
capacité de contrôler les infections
pour faire des chirurgies simple pour
ouvrir le corps par exemple pour des
césariennes pour faire des changements
l'ange pour faire des transplantations
d'organes des transplantation de moelle
osseuse des chimiothérapies l'art sans
antibiotiques
toutes ces procédures là deviennent plus
risquée voire impossible aujourd'hui la
majorité des infections sont encore très
table mais elles le sont de moins en
moins et si on fait rien les selon les
meilleures estimations d'ici 2050
la résistance aux antibiotiques
pourraient tuer dix millions de
personnes
ça ça veut dire que les maladies
infectieuses pourrait redevenir une des
principales causes de mortalité dans le
monde
il ya eu une prise de conscience dans
les dernières années le ms l'onu cetera
may est encore à à mobiliser les efforts
à l'échelle planétaire à tous les
paliers de gouvernement jusqu aux
citoyens qui doit être sensibilisé sur
l'utilisation d'antibiotiques
il faut réduire l'usagé d'antibiotiques
chez les humains et chez les animaux
d'élevage faut surveiller la propagation
des bactéries multirésistantes il faut
développer de nouveaux antibiotiques
trouver des moyens de motiver la
recherche fondamentale et de trouver de
nouvelles thérapies parce que le temps
est compté